charmaine there you are kate just told
me
not now i'm trying to put out a fire
yeah that's what i wanted to talk about
hi hello you must be the bennett moore
wedding party that's us
and this is my brother noah hi welcome
to look lodge
i can't wait to hear what wonderful
things we have in store for the week
uh you'll have to forgive us we're
dealing with a computer system
crash and unfortunately we've lost some
of our files
technology right can you just
please just remind me of what you
planned with stuart um i can get it all
sorted out
well my brother did all the planning
noah
what uh i did
but i did it through bill oh
of course you had your assistant do it
why should i be surprised i'll just call
him it's fine tini don't you know i
asked you to plan this because i wanted
you to be a part of my wedding
i thought you'd be all over it i would
hi
my name is lily i'm the other activities
director here at the lodge
i've just finished taking care of
another party so i'm
free it would be my honor to jump in
this is an important week and we can
make it really special
okay okay uh there are welcome baskets
full of local goodies being delivered to
your suites i highly recommend the
pumpkin butter scones
so how about you go relax on your
private terrace
while i finalize the itinerary with
noah yes definitely we can handle this
okay well that sounds good um i'll see
you at dinner then
perfect good you're keith thank you room
14.
and noah to meet you at the bar in say
30. sure thank you
you